prevalence of autism spectrum disorders
and the impact autism has had on the
individuals with the disorder as well as
their families in society this growing
awareness has been paralleled by an
increasing emphasis on the importance of
understanding and treating the disorder
an emphasis evident in the government as
well as in the research and clinical
communities research into autism and
neurodevelopmental disorders has become
one of the most perplexing and
interesting areas of neuroscience
inquiry but often producing more
questions than answers as you will hear
however our understanding of this once
enigmatic disorder is growing and with
deeper understanding comes the hope of
new treatments for families and children
with autism science is driven by the
desire to understand ourselves and the
world in which we live and through
understanding improving this world it
begins with a question it follows a path
sometimes meandering sometimes more
direct but always trying to gear towards
an answer it requires and involves
bright and patient people with different
and sometimes very conflicting ideas to
share information examine how all the
individual pieces fit together it needs
visionary people can imagine despite the
incompleteness and missing pictures what
the total picture might look like and it
above all requires people with
sensitivity and expertise and filling in
these gaps to complete the whole picture
it is only through collaboration and
integration of these different aspects
of scientific discovery and clinical
care that real progress is made I'm
proud to say that a partnership between
the provincially funded Ontario Brain
Institute and the Canadian Institute for
Advanced Research see far has created an
environment for this sort of meaningful
collaboration and exchange of ideas to
this week we've been very fortunate the
two groups to have a participate in a
workshop focused on understanding and
advancing of autism and this was held
before OPI and see far funded
researchers from across Ontario and
indeed across the world in attendance
are basic and translational scientists
hailing from multiple disciplines but
united under a common vision of finding
new ways to approach the research and
treatment of autism again looking to
fill in the missing pieces and again
gain insight to reveal a big picture and
this cross-pollination of ideas in a
forward-looking vision is just the start
one of the highlights of this workshop
is tonight's public lecture where you're
going to hear an overview of many of the
things that we shared an overview of
recent genetic advances in autism and
then we're going to follow this by a
panel of experts at the leading edge of
autism research this public lecture
reflects both OB eyes and CFR's
recognition of the necessity of moving
research beyond the lab and into hands
in the hands of those who can apply it
and again the importance of sharing
information with those who need it so
our integrated approach to knowledge
translation strives to involve all
involved all stakeholders such as
clinicians researchers industry patients
and their advocates and tonight is no
exception I would like to introduce Jill
Farber from Autism Speaks Canada whose
involvement made tonight's event
possible Jill was named vice chair of
autism Speaks Canada's Board of
Directors in January 2012 and has been a
member of the boards in September 2006
Jill is acted as the chair of the family
services community grants review
committee since the launch of the
program in 2010 and prior to her
involvement with autism Speaks Canada
Jill was a behavioural consultant and an
instructor trainer for children with
autism spectrum disorder and now I would
like to invite Jill to the states to say
a few words and introduce tonight's
speaker kill
good evening everyone thank you for
joining us tonight it's such an amazing
to be a part of this with all of you my
name is Jill Farber and I am the vice
chair of the board of directors of
autism speaks firstly I'd like to begin
by plotting Ontario Brain Institute and
the Canadian Institute for applied
research for bringing some of the lead
scientists in autism field in a workshop
forum in the last two days I've had the
privilege to listen to researchers from
all different modalities come together
as a cohesive group to collaborate and
discuss their questions their findings
and their leads into further
understanding the science of autism it
has been quite a learning experience
when CFR and OB I applied for a family
service grant from Autism Speaks Canada
to partner with us and sharing some of
this information with the public and
promoting knowledge transfer we jumped
on the opportunity we at Autism Speaks
Canada believe very strongly in both
collaboration and sharing knowledge
thank you for having us and allowing us
to be part of this very special evening
they have also given me a great honor to
introduce one of those great Canadian
minds he is one of the world's top
autism researchers he is a senior
scientist and director of the center of
applied genomics at the Hospital for
Sick killed sick children he did
professor of medicine and the director
of McLaughlin centre of molecular
medicine of the university of toronto he
sits on so many scientific boards and
has won numerous honors I could not
possibly name all of them in the three
minutes along with his credentials he is
a true researcher who spends a lot of
time in the lab because he is really
driven to make new discoveries and find
the genetic answers that will ultimately
help us move the science forward in the
field of autism best of all he is a nice
guy and a hockey dad he speaks to laymen
that would be me in layman's to
friends he does this because he gets
that knowledge transfer is so important
at all levels so I am honored to
introduce to all of you one of our great
canadian minds and a real nice scientist
dr. stephen share
you